Oh-ha-oh-oh-ah.
Ah-ah-ah.
Hello.
Ah.
Why does it feel like I have not... I mean I have streamed, but why does it feel like I have not streamed?
In a minute.
Well, I'm just embarrassed.
I'm just embarrassed.
I don't know why I'm hiding.
Hello everybody.
I sound better today.
Yeah, my voice is still not 100%.
It's still a little raspy.
But, uh, uh, yeah.
Just a little bit raspy.
Thanks for the five.
But I'm feeling so much better.
I still haven't taken my medicine for today.
Well, I took the first one this morning.
And after stream, I'm gonna take the other one, but I'm not gonna take it now because it makes my tummy hurt even more.
Hello, sicko.
Takanashi Kiara channel, hololive EN, hello.
I'm a sicko.
Hello, sicko.
What do you mean, in body or in mind?
Hey, Wawa.
That game you were playing today was whack.
Tika, thanks for the five gifted.
And Johnny, thanks for the five gifted.
I do sound less like a southern grandma.
Just a little bit of a southern grandma.
That game was so funny.
You're just going around punching everything.
Tis himself, thanks for the five gifted.
Yeah.
Oh, you're probably like, why isn't the game up?
I wanted to experience the intro and everything together.
Because it like throws me straight into the tutorial.
And I wanted to do, oh my gosh, all the gifted, thank you.
I wanted to do all the tutorial stuff together.
Ducky, thanks for the five gifted.
Spike, thanks for the 20 gifted.
I had like a single plot along the arm for it.
Hey, hey, hey.
This is not my office hours.
Star Creator, thanks for the 10 gifted.
I used to play this game with my aunt on our old PC.
It brings back memories, this and Rollercoaster Tycoon 3.
Yeah, I used to play this game all the time.
I used to play this game.
I used to play Rollercoaster Tycoon.
You know, like this, the Rollercoaster Tycoon, the Sims, the trifecta of simulation games back in the day.
Logan, thank you for the five.
Dark Disciple, thanks for the super chat.
Invisible Moose, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Here's my proposal.
What are we talking about?
Shoulder frills toggle doko?
Stop!
I feel, I feel, I feel so naked.
Don't take off my frills.
I, oh my gosh.
I feel like, I feel like I can't, I can't show you guys everything.
Because then when I get like, when I do get a new outfit and if it maybe like shows my shoulders or whatever, whatever.
Then you guys will be like, I already saw that.
I already saw, what's next?
Come on, catch up, catch up Mint Frentom.
We're on the next thing now.
So I'm like, I can't, I can't show you guys everything.
I have to save stuff for, for the future.
Whenever it happens, if it ever happens, I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll just never get a outfit that shows off my shoulders now because you guys have just seen everything apparently.
But quite honestly, even if I wanted to show my shoulders on stream, the rigging was not quite made for, for that.
So there were little things that I had to like, that I had to like erase out to post on Twitter.
If you saw the pictures on Twitter.
Because the rigging is like, oh yeah, we're made to, so you can see the frills.
But you guys think the frills are so cute, right?
So you want them all the time.
A sunset is beautiful no matter how many times you witness it.
Tuna.
Secret tuna riz.
Okay.
Gosh.
I heard that there was an all you can eat buffet at the cafe tonight.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I mostly have a cough really only when I talk, which is like so counterproductive.
For stream, but overall, I'm feeling like 80%.
I'm feeling so much better.
My nose is not completely stopped anymore.
I feel so good.
The medicine has been helping so much.
Who would have thunk, right?
Koiki... Koi... Koi... Koiyuki, sorry.
Thanks for the gifted.
Thank you for the superchat.
Are there still empty plots available?
Also, dark noodles!
Alright, I'll sing you happy birthday and then we'll start the game.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dark noodles.
Happy birthday!
The freaky ghost man has given me new knowledge.
I was playing a Miku song in Fortnite and noticed the otake going on in the background.
Something I wouldn't have noticed without you nerding out.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Me, all day, has been...
Okay, hold on.
First of all, I was like, I want Miku skin in Fortnite.
But honestly, I don't see myself ever using it.
Because I have Snake in Fortnite.
I don't think I'll ever change from him.
I don't think I'll ever stop using Snake.
But me, all day, I've just been being like...
When did we start using that song instead of...
But I like this one.
I think I might like it better than...
Even though it's a classic.
I'm thinking Miku, Miku.
It's so catchy!
Hold on.
That wasn't...
That wasn't sick cough.
That was me getting something stuck in my throat cough.
Boomer?
Maybe.
The frills are cute, but the person wearing it is cuter.
Chicken!
I wanted to post one of the...
Shaki keeps sending me stupid edits of my 3D model.
They're so funny.
When you and Kiara get married, will you take her color and become made mango?
What do you mean mango?
I think Kiara and I's colors already compliment each other.
Kiara has mint in her hair.
You know?
I mean, it's my birthday.
I just wanted to say thank you for making the past year so great.
I hope next year's gonna be even better.
Thanks PON!
Happy birthday!
Okay, now I sing you happy birthday.
And now we start the game.
Okay?
Oh my gosh.
I'm thinking Minto, Minto.
Synapse, I ain't giving you the super chat.
Okay.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear PON.
Happy birthday!
Alright, let's start up the game.
It might be a little loud at the beginning.
I think it's okay.
Let's go.
Microsoft Game Studios.
Blue fan.
These are so epic.
Wow!
Thank you for the 20 dollars.
Oh, it didn't throw me into the tutorial.
Oh my gosh.
It's so nostalgic.
Turn it down just a bit.
It
would be cool if you called your zoo Japari Park and fill it with servals.
But I don't think the game has any servals.
No!
Japari Park has so many different kinds of animals.
Frozen frog, thanks for 10 months.
10 months, sorry.
10 gifted!
We have to zoo keep Minto.
Why are we zoo keeping Minto?
Game franchise is 24 years old.
Apparently there is a new one, but it kind of sucks.
There's like one on Steam.
But the ratings, the reviews for it are not good.
Because it's not like this game where you get to build the enclosures and everything.
In that one, you are just like a zoo keeper.
And you like go and you like, you know, clean the animals.
It's like actual zoo keeper sim.
But this one is original zoo tycoon.
You will build the zoo and then free the animals and have them eat the people.
You can't kill people in the new one.
What's the point?
POV, you just got out of school and winding down.
Ma'am, let me just build my zoo and then I'll do my homework after.
Okay, ma'am?
Okay, let's do the tutorial because it's been a long time since I've played this game.
Oh, wait.
How many tutorials are there?
Very advanced.
Okay, hold on.
Let's just do...
Maybe we do...
They are like, you will become a zoo.
Oh, wait.
I can move the window.
Oh my gosh.
It was stuck in the corner for a bit.
Oh, thank goodness.
They are like, you will become a zoo tycoon master.
Great.
Welcome to Mabu's show.
Can you play super solvers, gizmos, and gadgets in the future?
I don't think I'm going to remember that.
I can't stop saying Minky.
I feel like I should have like a...
I've thought about doing like a Google Doc thing where people can submit game suggestions.
But I'm afraid it will become abused.
And become used like a marshmallow or something.
Thank you so much for the 5 dollars.
Makes me so happy to see my favorite little ghosty playing my child's favorite game.
Thank you.
This is the first game I ever remember modding.
No, wait.
What did you mod on Eskeleton?
Maybe that would be good.
To have like just a...
Oh my god, this song is already driving me crazy.
To have like a pinned community post.
Nameless, welcome to Mabu's show.
You can add new animals and buildings in the future.
McDonald's mod!
Okay, let's see.
Let's do the first tutorial.
Wow!
Oh, welcome to Zoo Tycoon.
We'll be playing soon.
But first, this brief introductory tutorial will teach you some of the important game controls of Zoo Tycoon.
When you play this tutorial, you will see a reminder text display in the upper section of the gameplay area.
Click this reminder panel to revisit the current tutorial's instructions.
First thing to learn is the game options tab.
Here.
Select a game.
Oh, look at him!
Wait, how do I zoom in?
Can I?
How do I zoom in?
I want to zoom in.
Oh, it won't let me yet.
Oh my gosh, all these little assets are so familiar.
Oh my god.
And I want to name all of our animals.
Like this one will be Minky.
Nine months.
Wow, wow, wow.
It takes knee socks.
Knee socks.
Woods of woods of woods.
Just signed a mortgage.
Woo, debt.
Fancy.
Congratulations, McMack.
Another... oh.
He's always wanted a brother.
Oh no, I'm blocking some of it.
Hold on.
Actually, okay, I never do this, but I'm going to have the game block me.
I never do this.
I never have the game block me.
But I shall.
Like so.
I'm thinking Minko, Minko.
Sorry.
Where we were.
There, where did that keyboard used?
Sounded so good, I just had to get it.
Oh my gosh, I hope you like it.
My only issue with it is it doesn't have a...
It doesn't have a print screen button.
So I had to write on a sticky note how to screenshot with the Windows Shift S.
A brother.
I always wanted a brother.
Wow, this place is kind of packed.
Why can't I move around?
Okay, let's just do the tutorial.
Let's view the Zoo Tycoon game world.
First, you can scroll the game map by moving the mouse cursor to the edge of the screen.
Like so.
Oh my god, we have actual Minkis.
He's hungry.
I'm hungry.
Wow, Minky.
Minky.
Actual Minky.
Minky won.
They're not very happy.
This zoo sucks.
What about the giraffes?
Oh, that guy is living his best life ever.
He's single though.
Are we sure he's happy?
Click on the zoom out button.
Nice, this is a tiny zoo.
Tiny, tiny zoo.
Rotating the game would allow you to see animals and buildings that might not be visible from the current view.
Although it was hard to see, there's a trash can behind the statue.
Okay, rotate.
Oh my god!
There really is a trash can.
How do I... okay.
Is this the only way to move?
I can't like drag around?
Kind of sucks.
Because it's like... it's kind of finicky.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
How do... oh my god.
There it is!
It's a single giraffe.
He's not bothered by anybody.
He's not held back by...
Wait, where did he go?
Minky is not happy!
Oh my... I'm hungry!
All my monkeys are so...
Oh my god.
Wait, I thought we named chimpanzee to Minky.
Minky.
Oh my god, all the chimpanzees are going...
What's wrong?
They're like freaking out.
Oh, I can move with arrow keys.
That's nice.
Yeah, this guy, he's like...
Hell yeah!
Oh, whoa!
Whoa, he's running!
Okay, I need to stop.
We're not even playing the game yet.
We're not even in the game yet and I'm already having a good time.
Okay.
Except the minkies are not having a good time.
Look at them!
Revolt!
Revolution!
Why aren't they happy?
They're gonna revolt like Planet of the Apes.
Yeah!
Maybe it's because there's so many.
Oh my god, they're really not happy.
Damn, I can't move them outside.
They hate him!
Oh my god, shut up!
Minky is not happy.
Okay, I'm rotating.
Okay, there we go.
Click the pause button.
Nice.
We can pause to get our bearings.
I'm just gonna sell this guy off.
I'm just gonna sell him.
Oh, we get a nice refund.
Damn, we're making good money.
Okay.
Another very useful is the undo previous action.
Oh, that's kinda nice.
Oh no!
I got infected!
We are the monkeys and she's the zookeeper.
Then you would be the ultimate happy, would you not?
Finally, let's learn how to remove or clear objects from the zoo.
Oh, let's bulldoze?
Okay, yeah.
Wait, how do I bulldoze?
Oh, it makes me wanna build...
Okay, it's like...
It's like you should build this and then delete it.
No, everybody, you can't be...
You...
You're not allowed to be a fool.
You must be hungry in my park.
And then undo.
Delete...
Oh, a section of the fence from the lion exhibit!
Oh my god.
Be free.
Be free!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Good grief, you've allowed the lions to run free in the zoo.
What were you thinking?
Well, we hope you learned your lesson.
Never trust the people who write these tutorials.
Never clear sections of fence in the lion's exhibit.
Unless you like seeing your guests flee in terror.
Okay.
Let's do the next tutorial.
Oh my gosh, camels!
Alright, basic gameplay.
Main menu.
First task is to build an exhibit.
Okay, we can do this.
It's gonna be huge.
It's gonna be ginormous.
Biggest exhibit ever.
Okay, guys?
It's gonna house the ultimate animal.
Oh.
Did I?
Oh, I already put it.
Okay.
Up against the fence.
It's like crazy.
You can see... you can be like two feet away from these animals.
It's just gonna take up the whole park.
What the hell is that?
Oh, the giraffes.
They're fighting.
Oh, we're making a Bengal tiger!
A mouse.
Yeah, we'll put a mouse in there.
Oh yeah, and this is the full expansion.
Who's throwing up in my park?
Fucking nasty children!
Get out of here!
Earth coin!
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
We're gonna...
Wait, so this is the complete collection.
So we do have a fish and we have dinosaurs.
So exciting, I know.
I wish this was an easier way to do this.
Oh, I wish I could like drag it, you know.
But one at a time, manually.
That's okay.
That's alright.
I'm patient.
I'm a patient...
I'm a patient kid.
Oh no!
No one tell her?
What do you mean?
I tried shift click.
That didn't work.
I thought there was click and drag.
Apparently not.
Mint one does not like the chat in its exhibit.
No!
What are you talking about?
You get placed in my exhibit and my happiness...
I'm just like sad faces.
Click and hold.
I tried that!
I'm holding right now.
It doesn't work.
Maybe I need to get to that part of the tutorial.
I don't know.
Tiger.
Okay.
Oh, but a yeti.
And a tiger.
Yuzu has its first Bengal tiger.
Left side of the game, higher staff.
Why did you sit down like that?
Make a path.
I think they can see.
I think they can see the tiger.
Oh my god.
Oh, I thought they were...
I thought the yeti was maybe a person in a suit.
And they were about to, you know, become the yeti.
Yeti guy exhibit.
Exactly.
Okay.
We're making a little pathway.
How many...
How much pathway do I need?
Place eight concrete paths.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
A burger stand.
I didn't really leave a lot of room for that.
There we go.
Now your patrons have a place to get something to eat.
What's next?
Why they're going to get thirsty.
Oh shoot.
Okay.
Yeah.
The pathway to the drink station.
Kazuhiro's Burgers.
Oh my gosh.
We have the name of that.
Don't we?
Someone's dying of thirst and they're like, oh my god.
I'm so thirsty.
I hope there's a drink place close by.
I have to walk to the other side of the zoo.
But do you want them to eat and drink standing up?
Let's place four picnic tables near the burger stand.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh.
Here.
There we go.
Mint burgers.
No.
Kazuhiro Burgers.
You're really getting the hang of this.
They're eating.
They're drinking.
What's missing?
Oh, restrooms.
I just...
What did I just do there?
Oh my gosh.
Imagine you pee in front of the giraffes.
What?
Birth?
Oh my gosh.
Happy birthday, Miki.
You're missing one last item.
Oh, trash can.
There.
Oh, three.
Okay.
Wait.
I accidentally placed something I didn't mean to.
Actually, I feel like we're pretty good.
Actually, this is important because the chimpanzees were miserable.
Why were they so upset?
Okay.
Suitable exhibit.
Oh, I forgot about this.
You can make the ground and stuff.
Can you put 500 alligators all over the place?
I just saw a great anime.
It's about a guy named Sanshi with eczema on his legs.
It's called Ichi Ni Sanshi.
Boo!
Wait.
Yeah, negative two.
Okay, on the left side, click the construction button.
This one?
Oh, okay.
So, from what I remember...
Hold on.
You can click and then you can see what they like, right?
Wait, how do you see what they like though?
Who has slept a long time ago?
Get this guy to bed.
You're a lion.
What else are you doing?
Okay.
Oh
my god, this guy.
Oh no, Mike Tigers.
Oh no, nobody's happy.
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
The tutorial is making me do the lions first.
The savannah grass.
Oh, look at how happy he's becoming.
But sometimes they like a little bit of grass.
Oh, okay.
Do it for the adjacent exhibit.
Place the correct terrain in the jaguar exhibit.
So, I have to go here.
Ah, see?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then it shows...
Okay, so it's here that shows what they like.
He's not sleepy, he's my brother.
Negative two.
Okay, jaguar likes rainforest.
This is the jaguar, right?
And then we can make it bigger, I remember.
They're happier, they're happy.
Oh, too much, too much grass.
Oh no, no, sorry.
Whee!
Okay, okay.
Oh, too much, too much, too much.
What?
It's a jaguar.
Is it not?
Or is it...
Yeah, jaguar.
What do you mean?
What do you guys call it?
It says leopard.
Oh shit!
Oopsie.
Wait, which one is that one?
Oh no!
There he is!
Okay, what does he like?
Oh, then we got lucky with the leopards, huh?
He wants the rainforest.
Why does he get such a sad, small exhibit?
Jaguar.
What?
What are you talking about?
Jaguar.
Why are you guys making fun of how I talk?
Jaguawa.
Don't make fun of how I talk.
It's like, one time...
Okay, I'm gonna say this and now you guys are always going to point it out whenever I say it.
But one time I was like, oh man, I won the game, yippee!
And someone was just like, won?
Don't you mean won?
And I was like, I won the game!
Yeah, I won the game!
And they're like, no, it's pronounced won the game.
I won the game.
And they're like, no!
Why?
And ever since then, I've always been so self-conscious about it.
And now I'm never gonna...
I'm just gonna call this a big kitty.
It's spelled jaguar.
But it's pronounced throat war for mangrove.
Okay, great.
Both exhibits now have terrain that the animals like.
Animals require more than just terrain.
Okay, now we're gonna add trees.
Place two trees in the lion exhibit.
Oh, okay.
Okay, two trees.
What?
Wait, he doesn't like that!
What does he want then?
Oh, this one?
He's like...
What?
Two grass trees?
He hates this thing!
I'm making him unhappy!
What?
Oops, did you notice that?
Oh, okay.
Float it up.
Please indicate the lion doesn't like this tree.
We can't imagine where you got the idea to do that.
These guys are gaslighters.
He hates trees.
Okay.
Delete tree.
Delete it, delete it, delete it.
He wants this instead.
Okay, four trees for you.
Lion one is unhappy.
Okay, click the big kitty.
Okay.
Four in the big kitty cage.
Okay, four in the big kitty cage.
Wait, what does he like?
What does he like?
He likes this one.
Four.
Big kitty.
He wants a gaming PC.
Big kitties love catwalk trees.
You can also discover how to make animals happy by viewing the zookeeper's recommendations.
Oh, here.
Okay, let's see what he says.
He needs more foliage.
There's too much grass.
This is reminding me...
Do you guys...
Do you guys see that episode of Courage the Cowardly Dog?
With little Muriel.
And she's like...
Less macaroni.
More cheese.
That's how I feel about this.
Too much grass.
Not enough dirt.
Too much rain for us.
Not enough water.
Improve the lion's exhibit suitability.
Look, he's so much happier though.
He would be happier with more rocks.
Okay, not enough dirt.
I like how you say words.
No.
I don't want to be a streamer anymore.
People make fun of the way I say words.
Sigh.
Dirt.
Okay, little tiny dirts.
Maybe... Is there too much grass?
Too much grass!
More dirt.
Too much grass.
You gotta remember to get the edges, you know?
Okay, too much grass.
Okay.
Now it's better.
More animals of the same type.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I just made a guy.
Okay, fight for her.
And then he wants some rocks.
He's always wanted a brother.
Not enough sand.
Too much dirt.
I hate this game.
Too much grass.
Not enough grass.
Not enough sand.
Too much dirt.
I love the way they sound so sad.
How's the volume, by the way?
Not enough shelters.
Fresh water.
Toy.
Okay.
Oh, there's something about the lion.
High maintenance lion.
I know, right?
Gosh.
Water.
Oh!
We did it!
The African lion is now quite happy with its exhibit.
You must complete just one more task before you are ready to manage your own zoo.
The zoo has been given two additional clouded leopards.
They have been placed in an exhibit that is not yet suitable for them.
Okay.
I know where these guys are.
Make a duplicate?
Of the...
Oh.
Like this?
So this is...
Wait.
This is a...
Huh?
So these are clouded leopards and then we got two more?
Okay.
This is exactly what I went through when I was like ten.
I never touched a tycoon game after.
Because these picky ass animals!
This is just too weird of a placement.
Do they like this?
Oh, yeah they do, baby.
Oh, yeah.
Do they like that?
Yeah, we're gonna make this like...
Oh, they hate that thing.
That's the ugliest tree I've ever seen.
Yeah, we like this tree instead.
What about this one?
Oh!
Oh, no.
That's an ugly ass tree.
We hate that tree.
Less macaroni.
More cheese.
Ew, someone's going to the bathroom.
Oh!
That's fancy.
And we can rotate it too.
Look at that.
And then shelters for these guys.
They need a shelter.
What do you mean you're not happy?
I'm working on it.
It's already so much better than before.
What are you talking about?
Hold on.
Needs more foliage.
Oh, a toy.
They want this.
This thing.
Oh, yeah.
And a rock.
Nope, never mind.
They don't want that rock.
More trees.
Okay, I'm just...
Oh, they hated this one.
I'm going to give them a lot of ferns.
Also, this exhibit sucks.
How are you supposed to see anything in it?
Okay.
We did it.
We've done it.
Okay, we don't need to do the next one.
Oh, God!
You're streaming being...
Oh, you're streaming 24-7 online while you were in Japan was very helpful while I was writing code that could tell me if the user was live.
Thanks for that.
Here's 10 bucks.
Oh, thanks.
Glad I could help.
Play.
Freeform game.
Oh, my gosh.
Where do we want to go?
We could just be in the middle of the ocean.
Dry river.
I think we should go for...
What's a large dino map?
Small city, my beloved.
Where is that?
Small volcano.
Death mountain?
That sounds intense.
Oh, small city.
There it is.
A small zoo in the middle of a city.
Epic.
Welcome to Mambo Ship.
Thank you.
Hmm...
Airport resort map.
This one seems kind of nice.
Lava lap.
Wow!
It has lava.
You guys, should we do a dinosaur map first thing?
Dino?
Okay.
I'm giving myself a high budget though.
I'm giving myself a high...
Wait, what's the highest we can do?
What if I give myself a million dollars?
Oh, I can't do that.
Okay.
Max it out?
Nah, we gotta have a little bit.
Above, above, above.
You know.
Oh, I hear it.
Whoa, these are so cool.
That's a lava pit.
Do you think the people will die here?
Do you think it'll...
Oh look, we can put sea dinos in there.
Do you think it'll explode?
It'll erupt.
All of this.
Can you still use windows?
Oh, it does erupt.
Oh my god, the people will die.
Yeah, I still use Windows 10.
You can't make me upgrade to Windows 11.
I have that on my laptop and I hate it.
I hate Windows 11.
Okay.
This seems like a good place.
Look, there's even like little geysers and stuff.
Large geysers, little geysers.
Nice.
Okay.
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh.
We can also get regular animals.
We can get whatever we want.
But we gotta get a giant sloth.
Gotta get that guy.
What have we got?
Oh look, they show you how to pronounce it.
Bigfoot!
Oh my gosh, I used to love this thing.
I don't know what the hell this thing is.
I used to love it.
It's so cute.
I don't know what the hell that thing is.
Also, I always used to laugh at the realistic polar bear.
Magnet the polar bear.
Like, who is that?
What's a...
Oh, here.
The Loch Ness Monster.
That'll be a good thing.
It's Magnet.
If you like dinosaurs, you should try Jurassic World 2 game.
Oh.
And wooly rhinoceros.
That guy can go...
Oh, giant tortoise.
Yeah.
These guys can go in here.
Oh, I remember the reindeer.
And the reindeer would be like...
And it would have Christmas music sometimes.
I remember.
Are these birds or are these like...
You know.
Okay.
What should be our first dinosaur?
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna build some facilities.
We're gonna build...
I always like to have a little...
A little...
What's it called?
Gift stand.
Like here.
Is there like a dino themed one?
Ah.
This.
This might be good.
Gift stand.
Alright, everybody.
Come in.
Hmm.
22 dollars.
Only gift stands.
Only gift stands and a long, long, long pathway.
All the way to see...
All the way to see this guy.
What should be our first guy?
Mel-chan!
Thanks for 9 months.
The restroom by the...
The single restroom is at the volcano.
Gosh, there's so many buildings.
There's so many buildings.
Oh, here we go.
Oh no!
Why not?
Oh, come on.
What?
A raptor?
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna do this.
And this.
We're gonna try for real, you guys.
This is like serious...
Gaming.
What?
I can't put it in between?
Okay, that kind of sucks.
I'm gonna put a tall torch.
Nope, nevermind.
I'm not gonna put that.
Look, this is the theming.
This is the theming.
Now we're locked in.
And then...
The benches are all stone.
Yeah.
I'm gonna have a small exhibit right here.
Go away.
There's always...
It's always best to have like an exhibit...
Right in the front.
You know what I mean?
To get them people like...
They're like...
It should be fine like this though, right?
I don't remember which ones need like the electric...
The electric chair.
Electric chair, electric chair.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
What should this be?
Gotta be something big at the front though.
You think?
I was thinking like a little...
Small teaser.
Like a...
Little...
You're like, wow.
Oh my gosh.
That's a thing at the front.
Sorry, I meant fence.
Electric fence.
I didn't mean chair.
Electric chair.
No, fence.
Sorry.
Hi, dad.
It's okay.
We still love you.
Whenever you talk Tommy Pickles.
A baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do.
I can...
I don't need this.
I don't need...
If I just put it to the back, right?
We don't need...
Along the wall, right?
That's how that works.
I don't know actually.
The wall...
The wall against...
Should be fine.
It is fine.
My brother and I bonded over this game as kids.
Brother.
Clever girl.
Praise me.
Okay.
All signs point to brother.
Okay, first exhibit.
And then we're gonna get rid of these.
Because we don't need them.
Save our money.
Atlantean tank wall.
Maybe like this guy.
Aster...
Astericosaurus.
Living medium to large size...
Maybe not.
Small...
Oh.
A Plateo...
Plateosaurus might be good.
He's a gentle little guy.
He's so gentle.
He means no harm.
Brother.
Or a Gallimimus.
Medium to large size.
No.
We need a small guy.
We need somebody who doesn't like people.
A Komodo dragon!
What's with the tar pit?
I don't know.
It was just there when I got here.
Wait, if I put this guy in...
Is he...
Oh, I forgot.
They start as eggs and then they hatch.
I forgot that.
That's so cute.
Asterigosaurus.
Us.
Does it mean you're sick?
Yeah, I am a little bit.
Do you unlock more animals or is this everything?
This is the guy that will break out.
I'm almost positive.
Allosaurus will break the barrier.
Right!
I kind of want to see it though.
We'll do it later.
Okay, let's just do a little...
This guy.
We'll put two of them.
They like deciduous forest.
Okay, alright.
I'm doing it.
Are there any people here?
Hello everybody!
You should join.
You should come to our park because it's very awesome.
We have dinosaurs now.
Hello!
Show me your kids!
Thanks for the gifted.
Oh my gosh.
What else do they like?
You like...
Oh no!
He needs a scientist.
Okay, scientist.
Get in there.
Let's do a tour guide.
A dinosaur recovery room?
We don't need that.
That's so silly.
Wait, does scientist take care of the dinosaurs too?
Oh, okay.
You're too slow.
Get in there.
How many Land Before Times have you seen?
I don't know.
Maybe...
Let's do a speedy recovery.
Thank you!
Thanks, Magister!
Alright.
See, they're getting healthier.
Okay, what else do they like?
This guy likes the gloss...
...trees.
Wait.
None of these look like that.
Uh-oh.
Wait, do I not have that tree?
The glossy tree?
Uh-oh.
I need to research it first.
Wait, how do I do that?
That was not in the tutorial.
What do you think of the park?
What do you think of the park, guest number three?
Look at that egg.
I've seen everything in the zoo.
I have to leave now.
Oh, you like a chimpanzee?
You're at the wrong part.
What are you people doing?
Oh my god, they're all sacrificing themselves.
Stop, she's going to sacrifice herself.
I've seen everything at the zoo.
Eek, I better not get too close to the lava pit.
Okay, maybe don't go off the path.
Hello?
Eek, the lava pit.
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm thirsty.
Oh my god.
You dumbass.
Go here.
Give me money.
How are you feeling?
Suitability zero.
Too much.
Okay, we need more water.
He does not like his exhibit.
There we go.
More water.
Does not like the tar pit.
But it's natural.
Thanks for the super chat, Jimmy.
More foliage.
More rocks.
Okay, more rocks.
We can do rocks.
Uh...
No...
Normal ass rocks.
Some small rocks.
I'm going to try...
The skinko tree.
Oh, see, they do like it.
What about this one?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is good.
They like it.
And...
Oh!
What about this?
Nice.
I knew that forest...
Oh, too many.
Just kidding.
Too much brownstone.
Not enough grass.
Not...
Too much sand.
Where the hell is sand?
Where is sand in your...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I got it.
Chill.
I understand.
They like that.
Oh, there's the sand.
Okay.
Too much...
Too much sand.
Not enough fresh water.
I got sick too.
Why did you get sick?
Don't get sick.
Okay.
Now a shelter.
And they're going to be...
So happy.
Like the happiest dinosaur burrow.
Get this...
Get this right in...
In here.
Somewhere.
Why can't I place it anywhere?
She's infecting us.
It wasn't me.
Maybe this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Never mind.
I didn't pass the sickness on to you.
You guys are just down with the sickness.
It's not my fault.
Okay.
I'm going to get rid of this rock.
Look at him go.
Okay.
And I'm going to get rid of this tree.
Just for now you guys.
Oh my god.
I'm so picky.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm going to add some more rocks.
Just for you guys.
My sweet little...
Platypuses.
Whatever you're called.
I don't remember your name.
I give you a better tree.
Sorry.
That scared me.
Parry the platypus.
Let's do another exhibit.
Still waiting on those 500 gators.
They are coming.
They're going to be...
They're going to be like the final exhibit.
Okay.
Oh.
Wow.
They're doing research all the way over here.
They're going to be like right...
No.
I feel like you need to go to the far side.
Of the place.
You know?
Can you rename a guest after me and drop me in the lava?
Okay.
Where are you?
Oh, here.
Guest 19.
No.
Guest...
Gezora.
Alright.
See you later.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
Here.
I'll just do this.
Alright.
Good luck getting home.
Good luck.
Good luck everybody else.
Alright.
Let's do one over here because these guys are pissing me off.
Why do they keep walking over there?
The exhibit is right here in front of you.
Oh.
No, no, no.
I don't...
I don't care.
I think I need to put the walking path closer.
How do I build paths again?
Hold on.
How do I build...
I know.
I know this.
I know this terrain.
Height.
Oh, zoo paths.
There we go.
Now everybody can get up and close and personal with our favorite little guys.
And they're so happy.
See?
They're so happy.
He says he's overjoyed.
They're overjoyed.
Okay.
What should we build right here?
Lava pit is way cooler than a zoo.
I...
Look at everybody.
Why do you care?
Why?
Oh, gross.
Pick that shit up.
Literally.
Look at this.
This is not an exhibit.
Wow.
That's not...
It's not part of the...
Drop me in a dinosaur enclosure?
Oh, sorry.
I forgot the L.
You were too stunned to speak.
Oh.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Now you're...
Now you're freaking out a little bit.
Oh, yeah.
I want to hear your screams.
Why aren't you screaming?
Why can't I hear your screams?
Hmm.
Anyway.
Guys, what do we...
Wow.
Small volcano.
That's so cool.
What is a dinosaur that likes this area?
You know?
Wait a second.
I think I put two girls in here.
You are...
Oh.
Yuri real?
If I put in a guy now though, that's a problematic age gap.
What do I do?
Love triangle?
No.
What do I do?
There's still year one.
Oh,
we got this guy now.
He's really colorful.
When do we get...
Saltwater crocodile.
We're getting the crocs.
Where is he?
Oh, my God.
Wolf.
This guy.
They're happy.
No.
You shouldn't be happy about that.
Mint strikes me as someone who wears crocs.
I don't.
I actually don't though.
A dinosaur ghost.
That's literally all around us.
I have a dinosaur as a pet.
A dinosaur ghost.
All ghosts have a dinosaur as a pet.
No shoulder frills Mint has summoned me.
I literally have the shoulders on.
What do you want from me?
Okay, let's build a really dangerous guy.
Let's build a dangerous...
Let's build a dangerous guy.
So dangerous that anybody who steps close is gonna get got.
So dangerous and scary.
Even looking at him might cause death.
He's that scary.
We're just gonna build it just like this.
Just like this.
Oh, yeah.
Who the hell is...
Wait, I don't have a bathroom here, do I?
Uh-oh, everybody's probably shitting their pants.
Hold on.
My bad, everybody.
Here you go.
All is well.
Let's do a couple bouncy guys.
You guys, we have to make the greatest zoo in the world first.
We have to make it the greatest zoo so our place is packed.
Everyone's just like, oh my god, I love this zoo so much.
It's the greatest zoo ever.
Oh, no.
And then we let them loose and we block the entrance and everybody dies.
That's what we got.
That's the strat.
That is the actual strat.
I know what I'm doing.
But first we have to play things proper, okay?
We have to make sure this place is so popular, though.
It's gotta be so popular first.
What the hell?
What was that boink, boink, boink, boink, boink, boink?
No!
Plotty!
He's sucking that up.
Oh, yeah.
Can you guys hear the game, by the way, or is it too low?
Just let me know.
All right, this looks kind of thin right now because I messed up a little bit.
It's going.
It sounds fine.
Okay, thank you, guys.
This is gonna be a pretty big enclosure.
Guys,
I think this guy was gonna get out.
Guys, I think I messed up a little bit.
Oh, oh, oh.
Does himself instead of five kisses.
It's okay.
We can remedy this.
Wait, what did I just do?
How did that drag?
I'm serious.
Oh, this is how you drag.
I figured out how.
So you have to place it first.
Ah, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
I figured it out.
Oh, thank God.
All right, and then here.
Oh, whoops.
I messed up again.
No, I messed up.
There we go.
Okay, like this, like so.
All right, this is a pretty big, pretty big exhibit.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's a pretty big exhibit.
Any dino would be lucky to have this exhibit.
This is like better...
This is better than like a...
Who the hell are you?
No way, don't tell me.
Is it?
Nope, you're guest 104.
Well, you're in the way.
And we'll probably get eaten.
Okay!
Yay!
Human.
What?
That's so messed up.
The human is loose.
Can you sit up there?
Thanks for the...
Thanks for the five.
All right, people are like getting anxious, you guys.
They're like, we need more dinos.
Stat.
Give us dinos or give us death.
Do these guys like to hang out?
Alone or in small family groups.
Okay.
That should be enough then.
They are a rainforest.
Rainforest kind of guys.
Nope, that's not a rainforest.
This is a rainforest.
Okay.
Kind of messed up having dinos next to fossils.
You know, it's just...
They have to be put in their place.
They can't just be like, Ah, we're dinos and we ride in the joint.
No, no, no.
They also need to know what is to come for them.
It's like when, you know, humans see cemeteries all the time.
You have to be reminded of your mortality.
That's...
Where the hell is this person going?
I can't stand these people.
Zoopath.
Oink, oink.
Oink.
Please let me drag.
Okay.
Whatever.
Good enough.
There's our scientist.
Kind of an inconvenient...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, good.
Hey.
Was that a Zoopals reference?
Old!
You got the reference, you old.
Let's get rid of this tree cause that tree is ugly.
They probably love this thing.
Mangrove tree?
They want 50 of them.
Durian tree?
Oh, yeah.
They're like, I live, breathe, die for the durians.
And they probably want this thing.
How do I...
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, it's already birthed.
It's already birthed!
Hello.
Oh, yeah.
Not enough fresh water, too much rainforest, not enough grass.
Okay.
More grass.
Fully this grass.
Grass.
Oh, yeah.
Happy little fellas.
So happy.
Look at them run!
Eat that guy.
Is that enough grass?
Too much rain...
Okay.
Now fresh water.
Too steep.
Walk cycle.
Hold on.
This one.
Down.
Down, drag.
There we go.
Maybe this area can go up.
Like here?
Oh, yeah.
I don't think he's happy.
Oh no, he's not happy.
Oh, he's not happy.
I'm working on it!
Is he gonna try and break out?
I'm working on it.
I'm working on it!
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think they're happy.
Guys.
Dinosaur revolt.
The minky revolution is now.
Oh.
Oh my god!
No!
You don't need to escape!
Does not like the rubble.
What rubble?
What are they talking about?
Oh no, he's trying to commit.
Oh no!
He's trying.
He's wanting to die.
He'd rather kill himself than be in this exhibit.
Oh my god.
He won't eat it out though, right?
It's electric.
Oh wow!
That's crazy.
What rubble are they talking about?
This thing?
Oh, they didn't like that.
Okay.
Okay, now let's...
Put in some fresh water.
Fresh water.
Does not like the rubble.
Those dumb dinos take down the trees they don't like.
Not enough fresh water still?
Is that enough?
Not enough grass.
Okay.
Are you really rainforest guys?
Cause like...
I don't know if that's true.
You sure don't like anything.
That is rainforesty.
Oh, this.
This they hate.
Okay, picky ass.
My god.
Now we just gotta put in a shelter.
And they'll be so much better.
They'll be feeling good.
There we go.
They're not feeling good.
It is well suited, but I don't think they...
I don't think they care.
Hold on!
Let's put in more stuff.
Do they want a toy?
What do dinosaurs like?
Show objects?
No.
Maybe some rocks?
Meat.
This one.
Oh yeah.
I'm working on it!
They like that?
Okay.
But the ranger didn't tell me to put in rocks and shit.
They're so unhappy.
What rubble?
What did you knock down now?
Oh my god.
They're so...
Oh my god!
It's getting better.
Oh no, too many rocks.
Do they like this?
Oh no, they liked that.
What was that?
That was a...
We'll just put a bush.
Okay,
this is good.
You like this tree?
I'm gonna get rid of this because it's too big.
It's fine.
They'll get over it.
Do they hate this?
Oh no, they liked that.
They hate that.
They only like a certain amount of them.
Oh my god, they're so picky.
They're so freaking picky.
Oh my god, I'm gonna lose my...
No, they hate that!
I'm gonna lose my mind over these stupid ass allosaurus.
Excellence in exhibit design.
At least one exhibit that is highly suitable.
Yeah, they're divas.
You guys help!
They're so awful to me.
I'm just trying to make them happy.
What about this?
Yeah, more of these.
I'm trying!
Oh my god.
This is such an ugly exhibit.
These guys suck.
No more durians.
What's this one?
I hate that.
What about this one?
We hate that.
More of these.
This exhibit sucks.
Why aren't you guys eating?
Oh my god, they're trying to starve themselves to death.
They're starving.
They have food right here!
Can they not reach it?
I wonder.
Now they can reach it.
Maybe.
He's eating.
Oh look, he's happy now.
He's happy now.
Offer them a goat.
I'm gonna give them a bongo.
They hate that.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, he's so much better now.
Hey, why aren't you eating?
You would...
I'm gonna give you a minky.
Wait, his food actually didn't go up.
Eat, you stupid ass!
Right there!
There they are.
They're trauma bonding.
That's why they don't...
This guy is so stupid.
He killed it for sport.
He does not like the rubble.
You made more rubble?
Are you kidding me?
But you said you liked that tree!
You said you liked it.
Why'd you get rid of it?
Why'd you kill it if you liked it?
Okay.
Whatever.
I'm done learning how you function.
Okay, they're happy now.
They're happy.
Okay, chat.
Since these guys are so picky and annoying, I'm gonna name them Chat 2.
Chat 1.
Put them in solitary confinement for being so ungrateful.
Solitary.
Okay.
They're better now though.
Everything's good now.
They're not trying to kill themselves.
Can't find any food.
Scientists, what are you doing?
What the hell are you doing?
Okay, we're gonna hire another scientist.
How's the ratings on my zoo?
Um...
69.
Why did it go down?
What about no animals and 500 snack machines and burger stands?
No, we gotta do this proper.
First time is proper, guys.
First time is proper.
And then we fuck it up.
And then we go apeshit.
Hot dog.
Oh yeah, hot dog stand.
Get your hot dogs.
Quality animal care.
That's right, baby.
I'm the best to ever do it.
I love how all these scientists are like, we're doing real research.
And I'm like, la la la.
Yeah.
Time to have people eat hot dogs in front of your research stand area.
Oh, here we go.
The paths, okay.
Okay, why can't I put anything there?
Little dino feet to uh...
Yeah, I'm gonna get rid of these.
Yes.
I'm gonna get rid of those and I'm gonna put in some...
Get rid of the dumpster.
We're gonna put in some places to eat.
You know.
The importance.
The essentials.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Like that.
Model it after Monkey Jungle.
The people are in the enclosure while the animals roam free outside.
They'll all kill each other though.
The humans, I mean.
Hot dog.
One hot dog, please.
Wait, how much do I have it set here?
Right, you sent too much.
It's only a two dollar hot dog.
It's a two dollar hot dog.
Then I get a soda too.
Okay.
Do people even use these?
Use this month only three times.
I think the children should not have fun.
What about this one?
Only one time?
Destroy, destroy.
Okay, are you guys eating well now?
Okay, good.
Dino gift shop.
Whoa, this place is huge.
Okay, destroy this tree.
And make...
This is what we do, you guys.
We destroy nature and make room for places that things can be bought at.
Oh, there's just like a tree in the middle of the walkway.
Oops.
We destroy nature so that we can play.
Move, you people.
I'm trying to...
Why doesn't anyone follow the damn...
The damn park.
The sidewalk.
Oh my god.
That was my favorite tree.
I apologize.
This is all in the name of capitalism.
Had to be done.
Uh oh.
You good?
Are you unhappy?
Are you trying to kill yourself again?
I dare you.
Chat, do it.
Yeah, I dare you.
Kill yourself!
He tried.
Zoo tycoon.
Alright.
Nice.
Look at our little area.
Look at our...
Look at our zoo.
But what nobody knows is that on the other side of the map...
Where'd that person go?
I wonder where they're at.
Remember we just let them wander out here?
I wonder where they went.
Do you think they left?
Wait.
Nope, that's a different guest.
What the hell are you guys doing out here?
Don't we have like signs that say no people beyond this point?
I just joined, but I...
I'm talking to the dinosaur.
Dinosaur.
I went home a while ago meant my oshi is streaming tonight.
No!
Where are you?
Wait, can we see like the name of the guest?
Oh, guest list.
Okay, hold on.
You couldn't have left!
You really did leave.
Column 007.
Zero successful escapes.
Zero happiness points.
Seven self-electrification.
We have someone who's hungry.
Okay, well maybe you should like find the burger.
Oh, that's why you're hungry?
You fucking dumbass!
I'm thirsty.
I need to go to the bathroom.
Oh my god!
You deserve to go in here.
Stupid guest 172.
Kill him!
Kill his ass!
Ouch!
I've been attacked by chat!
There's your food.
Chow down, baby.
Ouch!
Oh, he's fine now.
False alarm.
False alarm, everybody.
I'm okay.
This is drinks.
We'll put it...
Also, I forgot to mention.
We are a hot dog only establishment.
So there will be no other stands.
Oh, sorry.
I lied.
There will be no other stands.
Besides hot dogs.
But it was themed.
That's why I put it in.
It was themed.
Oh, and cotton candy.
We can allow cotton candy.
That's not a real food.
Oh.
Hot dogs only.
And some drinks, you know.
Anybody who's thirsty.
Oh, let's put in some more trash cans.
I think we only have one at the moment.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
Here, here.
Another one right here.
Perfect.
Hot dog!
Actually.
Exactly.
If you rename the tar pit into Minto's pit, I think it will be a popular attraction.
But the dinosaurs didn't like it.
That's so disappointing.
It's like so disappointing.
Hold on.
Can I add more tar pit?
Was it under here?
You think?
Oh wait, I forgot.
There's like things like this.
Like a fossil wall.
People will be like, whoa, fossil wall.
And we'll put in a Velociraptor statue.
This is what every good park has.
This little playful...
This guy next to the toilet.
Reinforce observation.
Oh, this is nice.
This is very fancy.
Let's have a map.
Does this really count as a zoo anymore?
It's like, oh man, I wonder what's at the zoo.
There's all two things.
Yeah, baby.
You get what you paid for here.
All two things.
Where's the tar pit?
Oh no.
Can we not buy the tar pit?
We'll put a geyser here.
Here, we can put this here.
I can't name it!
I was gonna name this Mintos Pits.
Look at our...
Look at our zoo.
It's pretty fantastic, if I do say so myself.
It's pretty incredible, actually.
I think I have what it takes to run a real zoo.
I'm just saying.
Okay, let's put our next guy... What should we do next?
Oh.
On the other... Oh, we have a stegosaurus!
Stegosaurus time, baby.
So easy.
I know!
That's what I'm saying.
We're gonna do a stegosaurus.
These guys are pretty chill.
We only need...
Oh, this one can work too, right?
These guys are so chill, we just need something like this.
They won't get out.
I mean, what if I even just did this?
They're so chill.
I'm gonna test it.
Nope, that's a monkey.
Scientists, get in there.
How chill are these guys?
Stegosaurus petting zoo.
Yeah!
They're just chill enough.
They're literally herbivores.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
I'm gonna get...
We'll get another tour guide.
We'll get another maintenance worker.
One more maintenance worker.
Scientists.
And scientists...
Yeah, you go to the...
I'll put you there.
Doesn't have the nostalgia factor of this game, but you might like Planet Zoo and Planet Coaster.
Maybe.
Current duty going to human.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Huh?
Let's just... Okay.
All of our animals have food.
When is he gonna hatch?
You can hear the toilet.
You want me to zoom in?
There you go.
Damn, this is a busy restroom.
That's what's going on in there.
Here, I'll build a second one right next to it.
Oink, oink, oink.
Oh, see?
There's like so many other cool things.
Oh, there's a dinosaur gift shop.
Wait, is that what it is?
Dinosaur gift shop.
Oh, this thing is huge.
It doesn't look like a dinosaur gift shop.
I thought we already built the dinosaur gift shop.
What is this then?
Oh, kid's dinosaur gift shop.
Okay.
Come on, hurry it up.
Yippee!
What else we got?
What's some new animals we got, baby?
We got a hyena.
We got a Siberian tiger.
We've got a Bigfoot!
We got a mandrill.
Multiple monkeys.
We've got a Jaguar.
Jaguar.
I think I misplaced my switch controller.
Can you use your supernatural maid powers to tell me where it is?
I think it's probably behind your bed.
Okay.
There he goes!
Uh oh.
Hey Stegosaurus, I'm gonna pick you up.
Oh no!
He's fine again.
He's back in his little exhibit.
Everything's okay.
He's chilling.
He's good.
He's doing well.
See?
Easy.
Don't do it!
Our rating just plummeted.
Okay, fine.
Goodbye, Stegosaurus.
Where's Stegosaurus?
What a silly guy.
Right!
Craziness.
Okay, our zoo rating is going back up.
Oh!
Yikes.
Where are these guys going?
Where are you going, actually?
You're monitoring the zoo?
Maybe do that over here.
Okay, thank you.
And you?
What are you doing?
You are monitoring... Okay, you're getting fired.
See ya!
Zoo recession?
No!
Okay, this one should be fine though.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
We're gonna do it like this.
And we're gonna make the people climb.
We're gonna make them work for this exhibit.
It's not the most interesting.
Here, we'll give a little pizzazz.
Like that.
There we go.
This is the Stegosaurus.
Oh wait, I forgot to name it Stegosaurus.
Stegosaurus.
And this guy...
Here we go.
I wonder when my guys are gonna give birth.
You think they're happy?
I wonder if I can see a little animal list.
Let's see.
Everybody seems...
Alright.
How are you doing?
Yeah.
Wait, didn't we have another one?
Another one?
Oh my god, the problematic age gap.
This guy's not an adult yet.
Oh my god.
The size difference.
It's like his mom.
Who said it would be fine?
You said he was still year one.
Not the Shodosaurus.
No!
Oh my god, no.
Give him food, scientist!
What are you doing?
Is anyone going?
Okay, here he goes.
While he's busy, while we're waiting.
Stegosaurus loves the coniferous forest.
And they love the leopard...
Don...
Don tree.
You think this will be too steep for them?
You think they'll be like, My little legs can't handle the steepness.
Yeah, that tree.
Too much sand.
Okay.
Alright.
And probably some fresh water.
Like that, you know.
Probably a little hideaway.
What does a Stegosaurus hide away in?
Oh!
When did I get so low on money?
Uh oh.
Uh.
Do you think they would be that, or the crawl one?
This one.
Small Stegosaurus.
Stegosaurus are kind of big.
Okay, we need people to come to our zoo.
Stat?
Um.
Uh.
Probably this one, right?
Oh gosh.
We don't have a lot of money.
Okay, I'm just gonna have to, uh.
This is the tree they love.
We can put a couple in.
Maybe like this one?
No.
What's a really tall one?
This one maybe.
Okay.
This is good, this is good.
And then some rocks.
Oh, pine bush.
We're just, we're just guessing.
Based on vibes.
This is purely vibe, vibe, vibe based.
Oh no!
I'm, oh my gosh, I'm like in the red.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Not enough trees.
Can I build a pathway?
So people will come and view said animal.
Okay.
I don't have enough money.
I think I need to have fire some people.
Um.
Where's my staff list?
Everybody?
Guys, oh, Scientist 1, Tour Guide 1.
We have fallen on some hard, hard times.
Tour Guide 2, you just have not been getting the ratings.
You have just not been meeting expectations.
I'm sorry.
You need to go.
Yes.
Uh, Maintenance Worker number 4.
We don't even, we only have two bathrooms.
Quite honestly.
Please leave the premises.
Uh, Scientist 4.
You, what the fuck are you doing?
I just said get out of here.
And now we should have more money.
Unassigned staff?
Wait.
Why do we have so many people unassigned?
I don't think we need tour guides after all.
It's not even that big of a zoo.
Okay.
Brother.
Oh my god, we're not even going to be able to pay you at this point.
Oh my god.
Five dollars for a plushie?
Sorry everybody.
Eight dollars.
What is this place called?
Oh, I thought it was called Kino Gift Shop.
Cause kids and dino.
No.
Kino Gift Shop.
They combined in my brain.
Psychotosaurus 2 hatched!
We have more.
Do we have anyone viewing them?
Okay, what?
Are you happy?
Oh, he's quite happy.
Oh, he's not quite happy.
Not enough dirt.
Does not like the cave.
You know what, that's great actually for us.
Get this shit out of here.
Thank you $1,000 baby.
Dino plushie please.
Thank you Kuya, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Some more dirt.
This is very expensive dirt.
Please understand, Stegosaurus.
Please understand.
Too much coniferous, not enough grass.
More animals?
That's too steep.
Does that cost money?
Does it cost money to lower?
No, okay.
No, we're good I think.
I think.
They crave the grass.
We'll give it to them.
They'll get grass.
They'll get it.
I went to Keno gift shop, but there's actually no Keno to be found.
Just plushies of dinosaurs.
What is a Keno?
I've seen people use it, but I don't know what it means actually.
I thought it was like the cinema, right?
Oh no, too much.
Okay, good now.
It's like cinema, okay.
It's like a masterpiece.
What are you saying?
My gift shop is not a masterpiece?
You saying that?
Not enough funds?
Oh no.
Oh, they like that though.
Actually, they like that a lot.
They want more grass.
You guys just might not be...
Oh no, they're knocking everything over.
Oh my god, no!
All of my trees!
You know how much these cost me?
You sons of bitches!
What else do you not like?
Does not like the rubble.
There's more?
What else did you knock over?
I don't see any more rubble.
You're making money again.
Am I?
Where's the rubble?
Can the visitors see this exhibit?
I don't know why they have no problem walking all the way the fuck over here.
Look at this!
But they won't walk over here.
I don't understand.
I don't get it.
It's not like the rubble.
Where's more rubble?
Oh, undo.
I'm working on it.
Oh, there it is.
I'm trying.
Oops.
Okay, we might have enough money to lower some of this.
That should be a bit better.
They want more guys.
You can hide trees behind rocks to prevent...
But they obviously don't like it though, right?
I think these guys are totally happy now.
They don't want to break out anymore.
They don't care that the stegosaurus are absolutely just...
Oh, never mind.
But look, he's overjoyed.
Chuu!
That's not mine!
Oh my god, we're so in the red.
Oh my god, what's happening?
Why are we so in debt?
Guys?
Why are we in debt?
Oh, I think I need to raise the prices of the zoo.
You guys are coming for dinosaurs.
Like, get over yourselves.
Look how many people are here.
Hot dogs stay the same price.
But cotton candy...
Oh, nope, nope, nope.
Three bucks.
Ten dollars.
For a plushie.
It's worth, everybody, it's worth it.
It's a panda.
We don't even have pandas here.
Crushed ice?
This is starting to feel like a real zoo.
Ten thousand people will pay it?
Really?
Even guests?
Oh my gosh, guest 400!
What do you think, guest 400?
Oh my god.
Empty-headed.
Here, come look at this.
Come look at this stegosaurus.
Come look, come look.
What do you think of that?
What do you think about that guy?
Really cool, huh?
There she goes.
When will we make money again?
Charge to use the toilets?
I can't do that.
It won't let me.
Otherwise, I totally would.
Hot dogs!
Get your hot dogs!
$1.50 hot dog.
Cheap, cheap, cheap hot dogs.
I have no money.
Funding has stopped for all programs.
Guys, I have to go.
Just a little ghosties room.
So...
Just keep my zoo...
Cheer when I get money.
I'm gonna let the zoo just run on its own, okay?
Who do you wanna watch?
Do you wanna watch these guys?
Which do you wanna watch?
Where'd that other guest go?
The gators are coming, by the way.
Oh, there she is.
What is she...
Still no thoughts.
Lava pit.
Okay, I'll let you watch the lava pit.
There you go.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
Little ghosties room for me.
Okay, guys.
I haven't looked yet.
But how much money have we made?
Grasshoppers existed since 20 million years ago.
Where did they hop for 55 million years?
Wait.
Grasshoppers existed since 145 million years ago.
But grasshoppers existed since 200 million years ago.
What?
Then who...
Wait.
Then who named them grasshoppers?
So they were...
It must have been a time traveler.
A time traveler...
Technology unlocked.
Pay toilets.
No way.
Really?
Don't lie to me.
A time traveler went back and was...
Oh my god.
Another one?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Which one did he made with?
Which one?
Which one made it?
We have to sell the other one.
The weaker one.
Uh-oh.
It's dying.
You guys, we're getting out of debt.
We're getting out of debt.
I know you're not happy, but like...
Guest 400 loves you.
I'm guessing that's Guest 400.
Yeah!
Oh, they're hungry.
You should spend money on a hotdog.
Maybe like 50 of them.
Where are you going?
No, the hotdog's right there!
Guest 400!
You're so stupid.
Kendo gift shop.
Makes only a profit of 100 dollars.
More hotdog.
I can't spend...
600!
Niki has such a cute and happy pee face.
Look how big they are.
Guys, I'm scared for our dinosaurs.
We're almost out of the red!
Oh my gosh, we're almost out of the red for real.
We're almost out of the red for real.
I think we gotta kill Plessio.
Oh, sorry.
Platty.
Not Plessiosaurus.
I'm stupid.
Like this guy.
Popcorn, please.
I don't sell that here!
No!
Stop paying the people!
Please.
Please stop paying the people.
Okay, you know what?
Get rid of the Stegosaurus.
They're not happy.
They hate it here.
I hate them.
Please go away.
You ruined my exhibits!
Get out of here.
I'll bring you back when the time is right.
The time is not right.
We need our money back.
We need our money back!
Okay!
Oh my god, imagine that happening.
These guys are huge now.
These guys are so big.
It is not big enough.
What about for this one?
Oh no!
And you want a kid?
Oh my god, it's born!
Oh my god, okay.
Oh no!
I'm sure all my favorite Stegosaurus are doing well.
No!
We can fix this.
Everybody?
What the hell?
Why is Santa Claus in my park?
Shoot him!
Shoot him down!
What the hell are you doing here, Santa?
Pay up!
You're on my property!
You need to pay the admission fee!
Okay, alright guys.
This is so sad.
But it's okay, because...
The visitors aren't gonna know what hit them.
Look at that.
We have so much more room now.
Okay, are you ready for this?
Sell all the staff!
Sell them off!
No new hires!
No new hires.
Scientists?
You have nothing to do?
You're getting out of here.
You're monitoring the zoo?
Get out of here!
Maintenance worker one?
Going to clean up?
Okay.
Monitoring zoo?
Get out of here!
Let's see.
Where should we release the beast?
Can I just release them, even if they don't have a cage?
Okay, I can't do that.
But all I have to do is make a teeny tiny cage.
And then, we'll release the beast.
I just realized that there were different things.
See, this would be perfect.
Zoo tycoon!
Oh, what the heck?
This zoo is just absolutely a failure.
A massive failure, everybody.
And I apologize on my part.
I apologize for my recklessness.
I apologize for thinking that I could turn this into the world's best zoo.
I have a lot of thirsty guests.
Are you guys in the park?
But I will go down with my ship.
And that's why I say...
Be free.
To the humans!
Do you think they know yet?
Okay, they're gonna get there eventually.
Okay, they don't know what's coming for them.
Block the gate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
Block the gate.
Pause.
Humans.
Okay, guys.
Guys, maybe go this way.
This way, this way.
Maybe I should make a pathway for them.
Hold on.
Let's make a little salt water...
They like salt water.
This is salt water crocodiles, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, is that salt?
I don't think that's salt water.
This way!
Cooking?
Barn owls existed 45 million years ago.
Barns have existed for 800 years.
I'm gonna leave Minky's wild zoo.
No, no, no!
There's no escape!
Oh, what?
They're all just swimming in the water.
Guys, it was a massive failure.
This is why we have plan B.
Run!
All these people are acting mighty calm.
Everybody here.
This guy is literally running into the fray.
I love the lag.
That's my favorite part.
Where's our other guy?
Get out of there!
No!
It's no time to be sad.
Actually, turn your sadness into anger!
Turn your sadness into distraction!
Oh my god!
Why are you angry?
They have no thoughts.
But they're angry about something.
Today's activity is survive.
They're still thirsty.
Despite it all.
I'm leaving the zoo.
Animals are running free.
I don't like the zoo at all.
I'm going to an amusement park.
Oh my god.
He's going for it.
Get him, chat!
Get him!
Where's the other guy?
The scientist is so chill.
What did he just do?
Oh my god!
He took out the Velociraptor statue!
Maintenance worker?
This guy has...
He's like...
I'm getting paid at least.
Well...
This is just...
What do you mean you can't find any food?
Go to the entrance!
The lag is so bad.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Oh yeah!
Who's screaming?
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Beautiful.
How's our crocodiles doing?
They're so chill.
They're like...
We're literally just crocodiles in the water.
Oh,
you weren't in the water.
But it showed you were in the water.
What about this guy?
The way they run is pretty freaky.
Look!
He was in the water.
What a bust.
Man, in two years we ran this place into the ground.
Look, he's laying down.
It's so cute.
I know it's because he's unhappy, but...
We couldn't even make it one whole year.
January 30th, everybody remembers.
In 15 days, everyone will remember.
What's our zoo name?
The experience.
It's the experience.
Everybody will remember what happened.
Everybody will remember.
The experience.
Okay, let's quit.
Boo!
Wait, how do I get here?
I know it's a bit of a shorter stream, but...
In the efforts to preserve my voice...
I think I might...
Get here.
I would like to do more Zoo Tycoon.
I want to do it.
I was actually trying.
That's what's so frustrating.
I actually was trying to have...
A legitimate...
Zoo experience.
Where we would make the best zoo.
And then...
Have it all go to shit.
But instead, we didn't even make it a year.
Business ownership too hard.
Right?
I know a lot of people are saying Planet Zoo.
So maybe we will try that.
A lot of people are saying about it.
But this one I wanted to definitely play for the...
Nostalgia, you know?
Speaking of Microsoft games...
Are you playing Microsoft Flight Simulator?
Someday I would like to.
Yeah.
Thanks for playing this game.
Thank you for watching this game.
Thanks Abby.
Thanks for two months.
Thanks for the streaming.
I hope you feel better soon.
After life finds a way.
Yeah, sorry.
Maybe Planet Zoo doesn't lag as much.
Yeah, the lagging does kind of...
Make it hard to play, right?
New Aquarian series started?
I don't even know about it.
Aquarian Moe?
I'm gonna look it up.
I apologize though if...
Some streams are shorter this...
This...
This week.
Maybe some next week too.
Did I miss much?
Was doing work stuff.
Yeah, missed it all.
You missed it all.
You missed when I got rid of...
You missed when I showed my bare shoulders.
Right everybody?
I did that.
Eventually.
Yeah, of course.
Anyway.
Thank you guys.
Sorry for the short stream.
Have a good rest of your day or your night.
And hopefully this was fun nostalgia.
It was for me for sure.
Such a blast from the past.
Yeah!
Thank you guys.
Bye bye.